we're asked to describe the behavior of
the function q around its vertical
asymptote at x equals negative three and
like always if you're familiar with this
i encourage you to pause it and see if
you can get some practice and if you're
not well i'm about to do it with you
all right so this is q of x it's defined
by a rational expression whenever i'm
dealing with asymptotes i like to factor
the numerators and the denominators so i
can make more sense of things so the
numerator here what two numbers well if
i were
their product is two and their sum is
three well that's two and one so i can
factor this as x plus one times x plus
two if that's unfamiliar to you i i
recommend you watch the videos on khan
academy on factoring quadratics
and over x plus three
and
x when x equals negative 1 or x equals
negative 2 would make the numerator
equal to zero without making the
denominator equal zero so those are
points where the function is equal to
zero but when x equals negative three
the denominator equals zero while the
numerator is not equal to zero so we're
dividing by zero and so that's a pretty
good sign of a vertical asymptote that
our function as we approach that value
is either going to pop up like that or
it's going to pop down or it's going to
pop down
like that or maybe
or or either way or could pop up like
that or it could go down something like
that but we're going to have a vertical
asymptote that the function as you
approach x equals negative 3 that the
function is going to approach
either positive infinity or negative
infinity or it might do positive
infinity from one direction or negative
infinity from another direction and if
this idea of directionality is a little
bit confusing well that's where we're
about that's what we're about to address
in this video
so let's just let me just draw a number
line here that focuses on these
interesting values
so
we care about x equals negative 3
and then the other interesting values
may be negative 2
negative 1. it's all there
now what does it mean to be approaching
x what is it what does it mean for x to
be approaching negative 3 from the
negative direction
and just to be clear this little
superscript right over here that means
we're approaching from the negative
direction
so that means we're approaching from
values more negative than negative three
so those are these values right over
here
we are approaching
we are approaching from that direction
another way another way to think about
it as we approach from the negative
direction we're on the interval x is
less than negative 3.
so let's think about what the what the
what the sign of q of x is going to be
as we're approaching negative 3
from that negative direction from the
left
well this if we have something less than
negative 3 and you add 1 this is going
to be negative
if you have something less than negative
3 and you add 2 that's going to be
negative as well if you have something
less than negative 3 and you add 3 well
that's going to be negative as well so a
negative times a negative is a positive
but then you divide by a negative it's
going to be a negative so q of x is
going to be negative on that interval so
as we approach and we have our vertical
asymptote we approach negative 3 from
the left hand side
well q of x is going to be negative and
so it's going to approach negative
infinity
so as as x approaches negative 3 from
the negative direction q of x is going
to approach negative infinity so at
least
this is accurate
this is accurate and this is accurate
right over here and you can validate
that try some values out try try
negative
let's let's see if you did negative
three point
you know q of
q of negative 3 point
negative 3.1 once again that's on the
left side it might be like right over
there actually probably be a little bit
for it might be something like this like
the scale
the scale that i've drawn it on q of
negative 3.1 if you want to verify it
it's going to be negative 3.1 plus 1
which is negative 2.1
times
negative 3.1 plus 2 which is negative
negative 1.1
1.1 i could put that in parentheses just
to make it clear
and then all of that is going to be over
well negative 3.1 plus 3 is going to be
is going to be
negative 0.1
so notice whatever we get up here this
positive value we're essentially going
to if we're dividing it by negative 0.1
that's like multiplying it by negative
10. so it's going to get it's going to
become a very negative value and if
instead of instead of it being negative
3.1 imagine if it was negative 3.01 then
this would be a zero one here this would
be a zero one here and this would be a
zero one here and so this denominator
you're dividing by negative 0.01 it's
going to be an even larger negative
value so you're going to approach
negative infinity so it's going to be
one of these two choices now let's think
about what happens as we approach x from
the positive direction and that's what
that's what this notation over there
means the superscript on the right hand
side the positive direction so we're
going to approach x from the positive
direction and i'm going to pay attention
in particular to the interval between
negative 2 and negative 3 because then
we know we don't have any weird sign
changes going on in the numerator so i
care about the interval negative 3 is
less than x which is less than negative
2. so i could draw an open circle here
to say we're not we're not considering
when we're at negative 2 and of course
we're not going to include negative 3
because our our function isn't defined
there but over this interval
so x plus 1 is still going to be
negative
x plus 1 is still going to be
negative if you took a negative 2.5 plus
1 it's going to be negative 1.5 x plus 2
is still going to be negative you're
taking values that are more negative
than negative 2 that are less than
negative 2. so you add 2 to that you're
still going to be negative and then
let's see if you add three
if you add three to these values
remember they're greater than negative
three or you could say they are less
negative than negative three
well then this is going to give you a
positive value
this is going to give you
a positive value and think about it q of
q of
i know negative 2.99
what is that going to be equal to if you
add 1 to that that is negative
1.99 and if you add 2 to that
times
negative 0.99
all of that over
negative 2.99 plus 3 well that's going
to be 0.01
so you can get a positive value on top
and then you're going to divide it by
0.01 that's the same thing as
multiplying by 100. so you're going to
get larger and larger values you're
going to approach infinity as you get
closer and closer to it from the right
hand side
so q of x is going to approach positive
infinity
so this is the choice that is correct
this one is wrong this says it's going
to approach negative infinity so that's
incorrect
and we will go
with
that choice